there is not one aspect of my life that
having a child did not change jennifer
nettles gets candid about raising
three-year-old son Magnus while
balancing the upcoming release of her
new album she is a seasoned little gypsy
baby you know world traveler he has more
skymiles at his age you know that I did
before I was 32 tour bus is different
the amount of free time I have is
different but that's that's the same
with any working parent you know your
life is completely changed fresh off a
starring role in Dolly Parton's coat of
many colors the sugarland alum is
lending her voice to a good cause and
lending her face to a popular cereal I
always knew clearly that the the problem
of hunger still exists in our country
but it wasn't until I heard the actual
numbers that one in seven Americans
suffers from hunger that is a
confronting number and when I heard that
I wanted to get involved with this
program without number hunger and and to
be able to hopefully make a difference
within folks at within their own
community for more information on how
you can help Jennifer outnumber hunger
visit ETonline com